we don't have to imagine anymore
elden ring so it has an open world with
roaming encounters that can be engaged
in different environments
our character can now use stealth they
can jump
and they can fight on horseback this
mount can double jump
it can boost jump and it can vanish into
thin air when you leap off of it
and you know as expected this game has a
really great sense of art direction
and world building elden ring is coming
to
current and next-gen consoles and pc
on january 21st 2022 but
until then let's just gush about this
trailer and talk about some of the
things that
it's really easy to miss the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace once lost
this first part reminds me of sakura's
opening cinematic
where the maiden approaches us after we
suffer a major setback as a character
this new maiden affectionately pats the
creature that
is or will be our mount she takes off
her ring for some reason
and she just instantly fulfills that
ever-present fire keeper role
that is so core to all of these games
and you see that enormous tree the
official site
calls it the erd tree and it quite
clearly
has its roots in yggdrasil the world
tree of norse mythology
and perhaps the world spiral tree of
berserk as well
but we'll talk about that in a lore
video to come so
subscribe for that at any rate the
official website
says that at the source of the erd tree
was the elden ring which has been
shattered
and now the tarnished will soon return
guided by grace
once lost so we play as these characters
and you know just as we were undead on
kindle dash
good hunters in previous games before
this
now we are tarnished so the word
tarnished has
two meanings first it's when something
usually a metal
loses its luster or becomes corroded
so take the valkyrie for example her arm
is
literally corroding it's losing its
luster
and even our hair as a tarnished appears
to have
lost that red luster that she and the
giant in the previous trailer
retain the other meaning of tarnish is
when something becomes
less valuable or less respected and
according to the official site
the tarnished were spurned by the grace
of gold
and exiled so thus they have become
less valuable or respected it's a
beautiful word to use for that reason
because both definitions of the word
seem to apply to the character so this
brings us to
the golden order from the website it
seems that we
as tarnished were once a part of it and
exiled from it
long ago but now the alden ring has been
shattered
and the golden order is broken
to its core
[Music]
let's talk about our mount who a lot of
people have started affectionately
calling
yakul on account of its similarity to
the red elk in
princess mononoke great movie this
wouldn't be the first time that miyazaki
or his designers maybe were inspired by
that movie
and yakul here is certainly capable of
some seriously gravity defying jumps
just like his movie counterpart
on the japanese elden ring site it's
actually called
a spirit horse which explains its
ability to suddenly appear
and vanish beneath us the way it appears
and disappears
also has interesting implications for
the gameplay imagine summoning yakul
in combat for a quick burst of speed or
just to make a getaway
it makes me wonder when it's beneficial
to engage in mounted combat
versus just traditional combat maybe
mounted combat is really
good against other mounted enemies for
example i mean that's what's happening
in this scene
after all the player character is
engaging in a sort of
joust with another mounted enemy holding
their sword
specifically to one side and then
releasing it at just the right moment
of course it doesn't look like mounted
combat is always going to be
this chivalrous the character in this
screenshot for example looks just about
ready to leap off of his horse
onto us and later on in the trailer we
actually do exactly that
here we're attacking this mob of hollows
and
this mob and the mounted enemy that we
fought earlier
they're all escorts for these two giants
and the carriage that they pull
via this spike and chain that is plunged
through their sort of cavernous chests
what's cool about this encounter is that
because this is an open world
wandering mobs like this will absolutely
venture through different territories
and
terrains meaning that every player might
encounter them
in different places with different
advantages and disadvantages
based on where and when they encountered
them
so that's exactly what's happening in
this screenshot according to a press
release that hasn't been that widely
circulated
eldon ring will have a natural weather
and
time of day progression and here we see
the player sneaking
in some tall grass their stealth
enhanced perhaps
by the cover of rainfall and night and
if the stealth system from secure
is truly in place then i bet you can
take out the caravan
one by one rather than taking them
head-on
in the daytime as we saw in the video
earlier
i bet the loot is pretty good too these
hollows are literally
carrying chests alongside the massive
chest
being carried by the giants so thinking
critically about
how to use the open world to your
advantage
sounds like so much fun and i bet you
can do the same thing here
with hal's moving castle so we all
noticed the giant
dong beneath the island but did you also
see that there's a building
above it i bet that you can watch and
wait
for this island to wander into different
territory and then maybe jump off
a nearby cliff onto the island open
world games are just
at their best with dynamic events and
puzzles
like this and it might be too early to
say this but
i think from software thinking really
creatively
about this kind of thing and i'm here
for it
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
the voice acting here is incredible it's
timed perfectly with the swell of the
music and
the scenery and the trailer but it's
that
flame of ambition line that i love the
most
because i think it speaks to the slight
tonal shift
this game has from dark souls dark souls
is the story of a downtrodden undead
trying to sort of hold on to the last
vestiges
of life but the tarnished instead
feel like they're fighting for their
right
to the glory lordship and status that
they've been denied that's a significant
difference
in my opinion and this increased sense
of
character agency translates well to an
open world where
you have more control over your path
where you choose which
castles to conquer or which caves to
explore
i'm also just really excited for the
gameplay variety that
this should introduce because you'll be
going between
you know exploring a big open world with
dynamic encounters
to exploring the more tightly designed
dungeons with the level design that we
know and love
from from software it'll be great to
sort of contrast
those two things right in many of these
darker dungeons and caves the character
wields a torch
which gives you light in exchange for a
shield or
two-handing your weapon speaking of
weapons though many seem to come with
animations that are pulled
straight from dark souls 3 to be honest
for example this
is the weapon art of the old wolf curved
sword
this is literally the quick step
animation you get from holding a dagger
or a short axe
this is the rolling attack of the short
bow and there are many
similar magic weapon arts as well they
will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
mentioned right after the spirit horse
part on the website
the website also mentions spirit bodies
which
appears to be summonable help that seem
a little bit more unique than the usual
phantoms
we summon in souls games there's even a
spirit bird in one of these screenshots
that reminds me of father al's
summon it's probably also a good time to
mention that this game has multiplayer
probably very similar to what we had in
dark souls so don't worry about that
but here is the last scene i want to
talk about in this segment
so it's night time here and it's more
evidence of a
rolling day and night system in the game
but most interesting is that this
character is sort of sitting
at a small camp so there is cut content
in dark souls
3 which showed that from software was
experimenting with the idea of
movable bonfires and checkpoints so what
if
they finally implemented this idea in
elden ring
what if you can move your camp around
starting back here
if you die it would make a lot of sense
right for an open world game like this
to have a movable checkpoint system and
i would bet that that's exactly what's
going on here
so according to namco's official site
it's our goal
to become the elden lord and
it's probably no coincidence that this
line about lords
aligns with our fight against the
valkyrie character who
is clearly a bit more lordly than we are
later when i feel more confident i will
talk more deeply about the law
that we know so far because there is a
bit more on the website and in other
places so
please subscribe for that now you might
have been too distracted by the
archdragon plucking lightning bolts from
the sky
to notice but you're yakul actually
performs a
double jump here shouts out to my twitch
chat
for noticing that one the player also
gets a jump
of their own just like in sakura so
expect a lot of verticality to be
present in these levels
and expect lots of hidden paths to
explore
well
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
this appears to be the same character
from the original trailer
who was stitching all these arms to
himself
he's been busy these past two years
apparently he now has
a cascade of limbs some clutching
additional weapons
to barrage you with he even stitches a
dragon head
onto one arm at some point
this character seems to be really
important and his main weapon has a lion
crest on it which
is the same crest that you see on many
enemies and banners throughout this
trailer
perhaps he's the main boss of this area
and speaking of which i assume this area
with the tree and with the plains and
the castle
i assume it's all part of just one
kingdom and that there are many other
open worlds to explore that we haven't
quite seen yet
so there are a lot more tiny secrets in
this trailer but thank you
for watching and supporting and just
enjoy watching this channel for the next
few weeks
as we discuss this game to death i'll
see you soon
you